what did you make of events in and
around the house of commons yesterday
according to conor burns the plan was
always to allow the privileges committee
to look into this matter they were just
concerned about the timing of all
i watched a gog as he said those words
to you in his interview
if they had the numbers they would have
defeated the motion yesterday they
actually put forward a wrecking
amendment on the day to try and scupper
the whole thing and yet they couldn't
even with a majority of 80
get that through so they pulled it out
at the last minute that means that there
isn't even enough tory mps who believe
that boris johnson is truthful to
actually get them to get them to walk
through the lobby to say so so that's
the situation they're in you could feel
yesterday the authority of boris johnson
and his government draining away and
conversely when you see the three
performances this week of secure stamina
and you see the three performances of
boris johnson i think it is quite clear
who is making the running who is leading
right now and who is leading a party
that's unified and got ideas beyond
partygate about how to tackle the
challenges in the economy in public
services and to tackle crime sure but
but what happens next i mean aren't we
excuse me aren't we now essentially in a
holding pattern until the privileges
committee is is in a position to look at
this matter that might not be for weeks
potentially even months well it's not
just that uh inquiry there's three
inquiries there's the sue grey inquiry
there's the police inquiries and now
there's the the privileges uh committee
inquiry which won't start incidentally
until the other ones are finished but
there is one inquiry it's already
completed and that is the inquiry into
the first party that he had at number
10. he has been sanctioned for that he
has a criminal sanction for that which
he's accepted he did so there's no need
to diddy or didn't he he's already been
deemed uh by having a criminal sanction
of failing and also he came to the to
parliament and he misled parliament over
the nature of it and he's just misled
and he's obfuscated he's refused to
engage with any of these going forward
saying that's the problem that's why
this won't go away because this
fundamentally speaks to his character
flaws as a leader he lies he is
untrustworthy
and he is incompetent and these are the
reasons why it's so important because
those same character flaws are the
reason why we have a low growth economy
in a high tax economy we have crime uh
the record levels it is now and we have
seven million people waiting for nhs
treatments it's all down to his
character flaws exposed by partyguide on
what basis are you so assured that the
public are actually with you on this
issue that the public genuinely care
fair enough the yougov poll suggests 79
of people think that he's live 61
percent of tory voters in 2019 i think
that he's lied but you know particularly
on the conservative end of all of that
his his ability to to bend the truth
many conservatives will say has already
been priced in such as it is
and that's a pretty cynical view if
that's their view indeed he can't even
carry emotion from his own backbenchers
to say that he has uh that he is an
honorable person that's a pretty
damning indictment of his own character
but the reason why the public need to be
really
aware of this and concerned about this
is as i've said the character flaws
exposed by partygate are the same
character flaws that have led to failure
in tackling crime in this country
tackling public services in this country
to just take for example the court
backlog 56 000 victims waiting for their
day in court
that is because it's being mismanaged
our economy is mismanaged which is why
we have the cost of living crisis next
friday people are going to see in their
paychecks a reduced income at the same
time as increased costs being demanded
of their their income this is all
because of the character flaws of boris
johnson which translates into the way
that his government is running our
country but doesn't the government have
a point when they say and they've said
this a number of times look there is an
awful lot for this government to be
doing right now you must concede ukraine
is one thing
free trade agreements with india the
cost of living crisis
isn't there a degree of truth to the
conservative position that you know what
there is an awful lot for us to be doing
right now we get it we understand the
criticism that's being laid at the door
of number 10 at boris johnson's front
door but
now's not the time
the point of a prime minister is to lead
great britain that means every day is a
really important day because every day
the person running our country who runs
our government is responsible for the
entire economy
there is never a day when it's not
important
so that means that every day is a day
where every day we don't have the best
person possible running our country is a
day where our economy is not succeeding
in not maximizing its potential our
public services aren't being well run
and the rest of the world is looking on
lacking the respect that britain
normally gets all of these things we're
not maximizing we're not getting the
best out of britain because of boris
johnson there is not a day which isn't
the right day to get a better leader
than boris johnson the tories are wising
up to it but if they go into these
elections and they ask the public to
solve their problem as a party by by
voting against him in such numbers that
they have to get rid of him think what
that says about the tory party rather
than being a political party which
exists to solve the public's problems
they're asking the public to solve
theirs that's the state of the current
tory party just a bit closer to your
brief however once again reports this
morning in the ft and i think elsewhere
as well that the government's preparing
to legislate to allow them to not tinker
but to tear up the northern ireland
protocol what's your view
this is absolutely astonishing and
incredibly damaging boris johnson uh
negotiated he drafted his team drafted
the north island protocol
they presented it but it's not what they
presented it to the eu they negotiated
it into the deal now by unilaterally
withdrawing it by breaking an
international commit commitment think
what this day actually entails boris
johnson is in india today trying to
start start the process of a new trade
deal and on the very day he's asking
president modi prime minister modi to
start the process of a new trade deal he
is pulling out of and breaking the last
one but genuinely it doesn't work as
well as it can do that's why the labor
policy is you build on it that means we
need to have an additional deal that can
smooth smooth veterinary services that
can pave the way for sps services so
things like fish food and animal feed
can get in these can be negotiated with
statecraft with diligence and with graft
all these things we know that boris
johnson is incapable of we can improve
the protocol we can smooth it and we can
do so without breaking the law and
breaking our international treaty we
signed with the eu if we just recklessly
pull out of it unilaterally how will any
other country in the world sign a deal
with us and think that we will honor it
how will prime minister modi react today
when boris johnson asks for a trade deal
if he is pulling out unilaterally of the
last trade deal he signed